when it comes to revenge fantasies
audiences these days are likely to
reference john wick or atomic blonde but
revenge cinema has a rich history with
some absolute classics that don't get
the recognition they deserve from 1980s
exploitation to lsd inspired madness
these are the best revenge movies you've
never seen
miz 45 is set in the sleazy streets of
1980s new york a grimy city covered in
garbage where there's danger around
every corner that's especially true if
you're a woman this town is just
crawling with predators during one
horrific day a mute seamstress named
thana is violently assaulted on two
occasions once on the street and once in
her apartment
after that second assault dana snaps and
morphs from quiet girl to murder machine
with a 45 pistol in her hand she trades
her drab dresses for red lipstick and
leather pants and begins prowling
through the city hunting for evil men at
night once she draws them out she
strikes and as the body count piles up
banana discovers that she really enjoys
filling dudes with lead after all her
name does come from thanatos the greek
god of death
directed by abel ferrara ms 45 is full
of unforgettable images like a crazed
killer dressed like a nun kissing her
bullets with ruby red lips before
loading them into her magazine
it's death wish meets carrie and even
though our leading lady barely makes a
sound when she picks up her pistol and
steps outside she's an angel of
vengeance who puts charles bronson to
shame
whether it's cabin in the woods style
horror or superhero blockbusters sam
raimi movies are always a blast and
that's just as true for the quick and
the dead this 1995 western finds sharon
stone riding into town like a
long-haired clint eastwood chomping down
on a cigar and looking for the man who
ruined her life known simply as the lady
this female gunslinger arrives at a
hellish desert outpost known as
redemption she's hoping to find the
maniacal outlaw named john herrod played
with an impressive menace by gene
hackman she plans on killing herod in
retaliation for her father's death years
prior and she plans on doing it in the
coolest way possible
see herod is the mayor of redemption and
he's hosting a tournament where the
baddest desperados in the land will
square off in the street and find out
who's the quickest draw as you can guess
by the title whoever doesn't win ends up
dead the lady plans on joining the
contest so she can put a bullet into
herod fair and square but her revenge
plan gets complicated as she runs across
a host of colorful characters each with
their own reason for joining this
twisted contest russell crowe plays a
killer turned man of the cloth who is
forced to play herod's game at the point
of a gun leonardo dicaprio steals every
scene he's in as the kid brash and cocky
and looking to impress someone important
keith david lance henriksen and tobin
bell fill out the rest of the cast to
say nothing of raymie's presence behind
the camera the quick and the dead bears
his trademark humor and techniques and
it's an over-the-top explosion of good
western fun it's slick and pulpy violent
and goofy basically it's everything
you'd expect from the guy who made evil
dead 2 an army of darkness
if you only know paddy considine as one
of the andes from hot fuzz then you're
in for a shock if you watch dead man's
shoes directed by shane meadows who
co-wrote the script with considine this
british thriller follows a soldier who's
returning home only he isn't expecting a
hero's welcome instead he's come back to
wreak some unholy vengeance played by
considine richard is nothing but
seething chaotic rage all bottled up and
ready to explode and you know this guy
has it out for somebody bad since his
first lines in the movie are shockingly
brutal
god will forgive them you'll forgive
them and allow them into heaven
i can't live with that
yeah richard is hardcore and he's after
some small time thugs who bullied and
tortured his mentally disabled brother
now that he's back home richard begins
taunting the men breaking into their
homes standing over them while they
sleep and freaking them out by donning
the world's creepiest gas mask it's all
horrific fun and terrifying games until
people start losing their lives armed
with everything from an axe to
drug-infused tea richard goes full-on
slasher villain but this film has a
depressing twist up its sleeve that
turns richard's revenge mission into an
odyssey of regret and self-loathing if
you want to see rage personified then
you should definitely check out dead
man's shoes
friedrich nietzsche has a famous and
often referenced quote
if you gaze long into an abyss the abyss
also gazes into you well picture
nietzsche writing that line while
holding a pen in one hand a meat cleaver
in the other and being absolutely
drenched with gore and that's the best
way to describe i saw the devil directed
by kim jiwoon this 2010 torture fest
totally earns its demonic title and
while it's a brilliant bit of filmmaking
it's absolute hell to watch the movie
opens with a woman stranded on the side
of the road waiting for a tow truck when
kyung chul played by old boy's choi min
sik shows up unfortunately kung chul is
a serial killer who takes great delight
in dismembering his victims so needless
to say things don't end well for the
poor woman however her fiance su yun
played by lieb yong-hun happens to be a
special agent who's pretty good at
dishing out pain driven by the hottest
anger imaginable tsuyun sets out after
the serial killer and catches him
quickly only to let him go
see tsuyun doesn't just want to kill
kyung chul he wants to play with him to
draw out the man's suffering it's a game
of cat and mouse a game where a lot of
bystanders get caught in the crossfire
what we've got here are two absolute
monsters one driven by evil and one
driven by hatred and pretty soon it's
hard to tell them apart the action here
is almost non-stop with insanely
choreographed fight scenes and gross out
moments that put the saw series to shame
don't eat anything before watching this
movie or you'll be seeing more than just
the devil you might just see your lunch
again
in most revenge movies the hero is some
sort of professional badass the bride is
an assassin maximus is a roman general
and hugh glass is a liver-eating
mountain man but what would happen if
some ordinary schlubby dude got a gun
and tried to go all john wick well
that's the premise of blue ruin a brutal
thriller by director jeremy sanye and
the answer is pretty simple it wouldn't
end well at all played to dweebish
perfection by macon blair his character
dwight has some serious issues he's
living in a beat up old car scrounging
through garbage cans and breaking into
empty homes so he can take showers he's
been homeless for a long time ever since
his parents were killed their deaths
have haunted him for years and now their
killer has just been paroled dwight has
been dreaming of revenge for a long long
time and he gets it within the first 20
minutes of the movie it's sloppy it's
sickening and it's totally realistic but
once you start a family feud the feuding
doesn't stop until everybody is dead
wait hurt my parents
i don't think you did
see once dwight gets his revenge the
family of the dead man comes calling and
they're all armed with some serious
hardware
dwight wants to be rambo but he's just
an ordinary dude he tries copying all
those action hero cliches like tending
his own wounds but it rarely works
dwight has no clue what he's doing but
with bad guys closing in he's forced to
make a stand no matter how foolish that
might be at times hilarious and other
times tragic blue ruin subverts one
action movie trope after another and
shows there's a really good reason that
revenge is best left on the big screen
directed by fashion designer tom ford
nocturnal animals will leave you
emotionally devastated drained of life
and terrified of driving at night the
story begins with amy adams playing the
role of susan morrow an incredibly
successful woman who runs an art gallery
and absolutely hates her life
she feels like a sellout her husband is
cheating on her and everything seems to
be falling apart that's when she
receives a novel called nocturnal
animals written by her old ex played by
jake gyllenhaal the book is dedicated to
susan but as she pours over the pages
she quickly discovers that's not a
compliment as she reads this twisted
book we're treated to a movie within a
movie where jake gyllenhaal shows up
again playing family man tony hastings
he's driving across texas with his wife
and daughter played by isla fisher and
ellie bamber respectively when they're
forced off the road by a gang of
rednecks led by a villainous aaron
taylor johnson honestly this roadside
confrontation is one of the scariest
moments ever made for a non-horror movie
and we're left with our jaws dropped in
shock when the creeps take off with
tony's family leaving him screaming on
the side of the road eventually tony
teams up with michael shannon's
no-nonsense lawman to hunt down the
thugs who attacked his family but that's
not the only revenge plot going on in
the film as susan gets deeper and deeper
into the novel we start learning more
about her relationship with the author
and we soon realize her literary ex
might have a serious axe to grind the
acting here is incredible all the way
around with taylor johnson delivering a
career best performance as the world's
sleaziest thug it's a cold and mean film
that will leave you shaken by the final
frame and in the end you'll never want
to take another road trip as long as you
live
shot on the endiest of indie budgets
mohawk is an action horror hybrid that
reminds us that american history is one
big bloodbath this 2017 flick follows a
trio of lovers an englishman played by
eamon ferran and two mohawk indians
played by kenitia horn and justin rayne
as they find themselves on the run from
a group of bloodthirsty americans tired
of seeing his people scalped and killed
reigns character mohawk warrior calvin
attacks an american camp and leaves
behind a bloody body count now the
remaining troops are out for blood and
their vicious commander played by ezra
buzzington will stop at nothing to get
his piece of manifest destiny with a
bunch of vengeful yankees on their trail
our trio tries to vanish into the woods
pulling every trick out of the mohawk
playbook to stay alive the forest is
vast and deep and will swallow you up
and the further the chase goes into the
woods the more mystical the movie gets
eventually the power dynamics change and
the focus on revenge shifts dramatically
the movie's last act goes straight into
horror territory and that should be no
surprise as the movie was directed by
ted gagan famous for his film we are
still here and co-written by horror
author grady hendrix the result is a
film that feels like the ritual meets
rambo complete with mutilation
decapitation and a lot of bloody
explosions
it's proof that you don't need a big
budget for big thrills and it's a
reminder that america's past is full of
death and destruction
take jodarovski's craziest movie black
sabbath's most metal album the scariest
cover of a stephen king novel then mix
them all together with a dash of a
hallucinogenic drug throw it in the
fires of hell for a few minutes and when
it's done cooking you'll get mandy one
of the wildest revenge movies ever made
set in 1983 this trippy gorefest finds
nicholas cage at his absolute cagieist
slamming vodka snorting cocaine and
forging his own axe to fight a gang of
cinebite bikers and oh yeah we've got a
cheddar goblin directed by panos
casmatos mandy starts as a gorgeous
lyrical love poem we watch as cage's
lumberjack red miller and his artist
wife the hauntingly beautiful mandy as
portrayed by andrea rysboro spend their
days alone in the woods they've carved
out a little paradise for themselves
where they can watch silly sci-fi movies
talk about astronomy and gaze at one
another after the sun sets
unfortunately mandy catches the eye of a
crazed folk singer turned cult leader
played by linus roach who desperately
wants her to join his freaky family when
she turns him down well this is a
revenge story after all and that's when
the movie shifts gears with red
summoning the power of every crazy
character that nicolas cage has ever
played armed with a crossbow he goes
toe-to-toe with the cult and a gang of
demon bikers there's an epic chainsaw
battle plenty of decapitations and in
between all the bloodshed we've got
psychedelic imagery galore with johann
johansson's brilliant score driving the
movie forward cage is an absolute beast
fighting demons and hunting hippies in
the most heavy metal movie ever made
the only out and out genre film from
spanish auteur pedro almodovar 2011's
the skin i live in has more twists than
a pretzel and more stomach sinking body
horror than any other entry on this list
loosely based on french author terry
novel tarantula the film centers on a
brilliant but cruel plastic surgeon
named robert ledgard portrayed through a
captivating performance by long time
ameldovar collaborator antonio banderas
consumed by the prospect of creating
synthetic burn resistant skin dr ledgard
is convinced he's on the verge of a
breakthrough thanks to his human guinea
pig a volatile bandaged patient played
by elena anaya who leadguard is holding
captive in his secluded estate for
mysterious reasons merging almodovar's
unmistakably vibrant sense of camp with
the skin crawling genre stylings of
david cronenberg georges franju and
lucio fulci the skin i live in premiered
at the 2011 cannes film festival where
it was nominated for the pomodor
the details of dr ledger's vendetta and
the lengths he's willing to go to see it
through are haunting and unforgettable
part hitchcockian identity thriller part
melodrama part macabre old hollywood
throwback the skin i live in is in
almodovar's own words a horror story
without screams or frights an
idiosyncratic entry both within elmo
davar's filmography and within the
revenge genre more broadly the skin i
live in is uncomfortable unpredictable
and an unforgettable viewing experience
for many moviegoers 1974's death wish is
the ultimate revenge movie but here's a
little secret death sentence is way
better and you don't have to take our
word for it even though we really do
think it's a massively underrated action
movie brian garfield the author of the
novel that inspired death wish called
death sentence a quote stunningly good
movie about the stupidity of vengeful
vigilantism and at the center of this
bullet-riddled film there's kevin bacon
giving one of his all-time best
performances as a family man turned
psycho killer directed by james wan
death sentence finds bacon as nick hume
a loving husband and good father whose
life is ripped apart when gangsters
brutally kill his son realizing the
justice system will let him down nick
foolishly takes the law into his own
hands sparking a war between this middle
class dad and some pistol packing drug
dealers things spiral out of control
fast giving us some incredibly tense
action scenes like a desperate foot
chase of a parking garage or the final
shootout in the blood red church and the
performances here are all scary good
especially with john goodman chewing up
the scenery as a foul-mouthed arms
dealer kill the little piss pants
see if it makes a down day's difference
to me
dad to dad
don't tell me about it
but the real highlight here is bacon
morphing from mild-mannered businessman
into an absolute animal after a series
of horrible decisions he's got nothing
left to lose and while these bad guys
definitely deserve a load of buckshot to
the face
death sentence is a harsh reminder of
what would actually happen if you turned
vigilante you'd lose everything dear to
you including your soul
thanks to the genre fluid genius of
brian de palma we're thrilled to include
the greatest revenge fueled rock opera
farce horror comedy ever made okay the
only one ever made
released in 1974 phantom of the paradise
is a joyfully bonkers mashup of three
classic spooky tales of obsession and
violent comeuppance gaston leroux the
phantom of the opera oscar wildes the
picture of dorian gray and the legend of
faust the film itself centers on a
talented if woefully naive songwriter
named winslow leach played by william
finley who's duped into selling his
life's work a cantata based on the faust
myth to a devilish music producer named
swan played by paul williams horribly
disfigured in his attempts to regain
control of his music leech dawn's a
menacing masked persona in an attempt to
sabotage swan's glorious new concert
hall the paradise when phantom of the
paradise premiered it bombed pretty much
everywhere but a passionate fandom
ensured that phantom of the paradise
survived and thrived going from b-movie
flop to a riotous cult classic it has
everything music murder a character
named beef
and for such an acrid satire of the
predatory soul-stealing nature of the
music industry phantom of the paradise
is overflowing with back to back bangers
unabashedly strange and infectiously
maniacal self-destructive revenge quests
are rarely this fun
one of the most visually striking and
atmospheric westerns ever produced
1968's the great silence is an icy tale
of the tragic limits of eye for an eye
frontier justice directed and co-written
by sergio corbucci sergio leone's only
real competition in the realm of
spaghetti westerns the great silence is
a bleak and strikingly beautiful
examination of the twisted morality of
bounty law and contract killers that
define the mythos of the wild west sat
in a snow swept mountain range as
unforgiving as the bloodthirsty bounty
hunters that stalk its valleys in search
of profit the film follows jean-louis
chatenyan he portrays a mute gunslinger
nicknamed silence
he's a gun for hire whose vocal cords
were slashed in childhood by the
mercenary miscreants who killed his
parents pitted against the sadistic and
gloriously campy bounty hunter known as
loco played appropriately mad by klaus
kinski silence attempts to defend those
on the receiving end of a justice system
that favors deep pockets one of the
great revisionist westerns the great
silence is a pessimistic and scathing
tale of the moral ambiguities of the
wild west and the never ending bloodshed
of revenge killings unforgiving and
shockingly unsentimental it boasts one
of the bleakest endings in genre film
matilda anna ingrid lutz is jen a bubbly
uncomplicated girl who tags along with
her very wealthy and very married
boyfriend richard played by kevin
jensens they're off for a romantic
getaway in the desert before his annual
hunting trip but after richard's buddies
show up early tensions rise and one of
his friends sexually assaults jen when
jen refuses to go quietly in the
aftermath richard chases her off of a
cliff but jen doesn't die not only that
she fights back
soon enough richard's casual hunting
trip with the boys takes a decidedly
murderous turn karlif arjaj's feature
film debut hits the ground running and
never looks back filmed in a joyfully
garish and pointedly self-aware parody
of the male gaze revenge takes the
misogyny tinged i spit on your grave
style revenge offerings that came before
it and flips them on their head we feel
surprised by what jen is capable of in
part because we're so used to seeing
women like jen underestimated in genre
films decked out in hot pink a lollipop
dangling from her glossy lips she's the
last person you'd expect to
self-cauterize a wound with a beer can
while tripping on peyote in a cave
and yet there she is outsmarting and
outlasting her would-be killers with the
ferocity of a seasoned survivalist
setting its tactical sights clearly on
male entitlement revenge is a brutal
blunt and decidedly bloody amalgamation
of feminism and exploitation cinema set
in medieval sweden two devout christians
toray played by max vancito and marita
brought to life by vergeta valberg send
their virginal daughter karen played by
bergida peterson and their pregnant
servant inger played by gunnel lindbloom
to deliver candles in a far-flung church
while they make their way through a
foreboding forest the pair are surprised
by a band of roving goat herders who
assault and kill karen while ingare
remains hidden later the three killers
seek refuge at toure and meritus
farmhouse unwittingly finding asylum in
the home of their victim's parents
overwhelmed with grief and the desire
for retribution fitting of the crime
toure plots his revenge melding
exploitation cinema and medieval
symbolism the virgin spring is cruel
slow burning and subtly horrific winner
of the academy award for best foreign
language film it's one of the few films
ingmar bergman directed but did not
write and yet bergman's career defining
austerity and spiritual critique have
arguably never been more visceral a
guttural fable of a world teetering
between paganism and christianity
bergman's guilt-soaked parable is a
gorgeous rendering of truly hideous
subject matter the plot of the virgin
spring would go on to form the basis of
wes craven's infamous 1972 film the last
house on the left which as author
alexandra heller nicholas notes suggests
that rape revenge films indeed possess
quote a relatively auspicious heritage
dutch director paul verhoeven's
triumphant return to form offers a
boldly subversive take on a well-worn
revenge formula when video game company
ceo michelle brought to life by isabel
upair is assaulted in her home she
refuses to let the incident shake her
carefully crafted life determined to
uncover the identity of her unknown
attacker michelle returns to business as
usual while coaxing her assailant into a
sinister game of cat and mouse
manipulating the violent desires of her
attacker premiering in competition for
the pomodoro at the 2016 cannes film
festival and ending in a seven minute
standing ovation even with such high
risk material elle has enjoyed
widespread critical acclaim with pointed
and deserving praise for upeira's
performance
heralded by variety as a possible career
high for verhoeven l is a knowingly
incendiary and twisted tale that's
certainly not for the faint of heart
in the late 19th century a dying
imprisoned woman gives birth to a baby
girl naming her yuki after the delicate
snow falling outside beyond their barred
window before she dies she utters her
final wish you will carry on my vendetta
my poor child her mother's wrath made
flesh yuki portrayed by a lethal
makokaji sharpens herself into the
perfect weapon what follows is a
bittersweet bloodbath of jaw-dropping
violence and spectacular swordplay a
frigid tragedy of intergenerational fury
dripping in style based on kazuo koika
and kazuo kamemara's manga series of the
same name toshiya fujita's elegant and
uber international genre masterpiece is
one of the cornerstones of asian action
cinema lady snowblood is a revenge
riddled must for international genre
fans
directed by mike hodges i'll sleep when
i'm dead is a haunting thriller about a
gangster who's returned to his old
stomping grounds and finds his world has
fallen apart clive owen plays will
graham a mob boss who left the london
underworld and has spent the last few
years living in the wilderness hounded
by guilt and regret he's completely cut
himself off from the world but you can't
ghost your friends and family and expect
everything to be okay that's a lesson
will learns the hard way when he
discovers his little brother davey
played by jonathan rhys myers has killed
himself wanting answers for davey's
death will returns to the life he left
behind and learns there's some sick
stuff going down an old london town
davey's death might have something to do
with an evil power player named bode
portrayed by the always brilliant
malcolm mcdowell will's return ignites a
turf war an old romance and feelings of
guilt for leaving his brother behind
one of the finest british gangster
movies this picture creeps along at a
steady pace slowly winding its way
through dark london neighborhoods its
neo-noir at its most brooding and clive
owen is brilliant here so quiet and so
intense brimming with anger and
struggling with grief for a life wasted
both his brothers and his own and as the
movie moves toward the final act of
revenge we're reminded that every
decision comes with a cost and you're
always going to pay no matter how far
you run or how long you hide
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luber videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]